so because of a weakened immune system
they pull the tooth out this mucor is
opportunistic Boom it enters through a
tooth and you're saying it went to his
brain yeah so it went up through his
sinuses and everything because you know
you got all the blood vessels right
there all the nerves and all that and
how long does it take how long does it
take to travel to your brain is it hours
is it days once you get the infection I
think it's pretty quick so the first day
they got there once they kind of figured
it out they went and like went up
through his nose and surgically removed
his sinuses like part of his sinuses
like you know these anti-fungals we have
like we were trying like the biggest
ones and it just wasn't doing anything
because it had been so bad it was so bad
when he got to the hospital and it
actually went up into his brain and they
were talking about having to go in I
think they were trying to they had to
respect part of his brain are you
serious he lived yes no no he was yeah
no no most of these people did not live
yeah